[Müzik]
Merhabalar ismim Hüseyin Çağlar ince Bio
mühendisim ve doğa farkındalığı
konusunda uzun yıllardır Türkiye'de
çalışmalar yapıyorum bugün biraz Bu
hazinelerimizden biraz da bu
hazinelerimizle yolculuğumuzdan kısaca
size bahsetmek istiyorum
Tabii doğal farkında olma başlangıcın
üniversite yıllarına dayanıyor ve o
dönemde kurduğumuz kuş gözlem topluluğu
ve sonraki süreçte yaptığınız
çalışmalarla Türkiye'nin Gerçekten
muhteşem bir Doğa hazinesine şahitlik
etme şansına eriştim
başlangıcında size bu hazinelerden
kısaca bahsetmek için kısa bir bilgi
vermek istiyorum 2005 yılında
Dünya Doğayı Koruma Kurumu dünyadaki
sıcak noktaları belirledikleri bir kitap
yayınladılar nasıl bir kitaptı bu özeti
Aslında kitabın içindeki bu haritada
Yani dünyada nesli tehlike altında olan
tükenmek üzere olan endemik dediğimiz
türleri
canlıların yoğunlaştığı bölgeleri sıcak
nokta olarak belirledik şu anda
gördüğünüz o kırmızıya boyalı yerlerin
hepsi birer sıcak nokta mesela
Madagaskar Adası var Afrika'nın Doğu
tarafında Orası bir sıcak nokta ya da
Brezilya Yağmur ormanlarının bulunduğu
alan bir sıcak nokta Türkiye'ye
bakıyoruz Türkiye'ye özelleştiren kısmı
şu; dünyada çok az ülkede bu şansı
erişmiş durumda 3 tane sıcak noktanın
bir arada olduğu çok nadir ülkelerden
birisi Türkiye
baktığınızda Kafkasya sıcak noktasını
İran Turan Anadolu hattını görüyorsunuz
ve Akdeniz sıcak noktası Bu ne anlama
geliyor biliyor musunuz Yani dünyadaki
canlı çeşidine baktığımızda Türkiye'yi
alın komple bir Milli Parkı ilan edip
koruma altına alın orası dünyanın en
önemli biyolojik rezervlerinden bir
tanesi olarak öne çıkıyor bu gerçekten
çok önemli ve çok ciddi bir veri Aslında
abi bizim için mesela var Yeryüzünde
sadece Türkiye'de yaşam bulan 3 binin
üzerinde bitki türü var burada tüm
Avrupa'da 450 kadar kuş kelebek türü
varken Türkiye'de de toplamda 450 kadar
kelebek türü var mesela Akdeniz foku var
tüm dünyada 700 birey kalmış 100 lirayı
Türkiye kıyılarında yaşıyor gerçekten
Büyük Hazine büyük makamlar dünyadaki
bütün doğa koruma bütçesinin Türk
çıkması gerektiği bir rakamlar Bunlar
Ama ne yazık ki Bu rakamlar doğayı
korumaya yetmiyor Tam burada
Ben de sizlerle kendi
hikayemle birlikte paylaşacağım bir
fikir önerimi aslında sunmak istiyorum
şöyle
2005 yılında
eve denk geliyor Biz
Türkiye'nin ilk büyük çevre mitingi için
ankara'daydık tabi o döneme kadar aile
ilgili birçok çalışma yaptık ve doğada
yaşam bulan bir ailenin içinden
geliyordum Daha doğrusu kültürel kodları
yörükleye dayanan bir ailenin içinden
geliyordum ki Dedem ve babam böyle bir
yaşamın içerisinde doğmuştu Dolayısıyla
Bu şu anlama geliyor Aslında
dağın taşın işte kuşun kelebeğin hepsini
bir insan gibi karakterize edildiği ve
insanların yaşamında var olması yani
doğa ile uyumlu kültürlerde böyledir
Aslında Doğanın insan yaşamında kültür
oluşma çok büyük etkisi vardır
Dolayısıyla benim de Çocukluğum
turnaların hikayeleriyle muayeneleriyle
geçti Ve dünyaya da bakış ım hiçbir
zaman kültürle doğayı ayırmadı ve
birlikte
Tabii Yıllar yılı geçti Biz dediğim gibi
Ankara'da 2005 yılında büyük bir çevre
mitingi hazırlığındaydık ama o dönemde
çevreci söylemler doğa ile ilgili
çalışmalar son derece romantik kalıyordu
Çünkü dünyanın bir 20 sene içerisinde
doğa ve plaketleri ile karşı karşıya
kalınacağından kimsenin haberi yoktu o
kadar renkliydi ki mesela bu ağız içi
Köprüsü'nden pankartla sarkan arkadaşlar
bizim gibi kendini ağaçlara zincirleyen
böyle genç çocuklar bunlar Herkes
tarafından büyük sempatiyle
karşılaşıyordu ama talep görmüyordu
sadece uzaktan sempatik geliyordu bir
miting düzenleyeceğiz o dönemin
kurallarına göre şöyle bir şey izledik
çünkü o dönemde bir eylem yaptığınızda
Kızılay meydanında bir sokakta polisle
karşı karşıya Gelirseniz 90'lardaki
2000'lerdeki haber bültenlerinin
anımsayabilirsiniz burada akşam ana
haberdesiniz Biz de pazar günkü mitingi
davet etmek için müthiş bir fikrimiz var
dedik ki 8-10 kişiyiz böyle rengarenk
tişörtler giymişiz Kızılay meydanına
indik fikrimiz de şu elimizde bir küçük
tüp bir tava bir un biraz tereyağı yok
olan doğal Helvasını kavuracağız bize
göre Gerçekten harika bir fikir
müthiş yaratıcı inovatif bir fikir oraya
dizildik Tabii tecrübe siziz Biz Eylem
yapmamışız daha önce daha önce miting de
düzenlememiz aslında
meydana vardık işte bir kenarda
duruyoruz Hatta göstereyim şu şekilde
duruyoruz rengarenk ve
oradaki gazetecilerden birinin yanına
yanaştım dedim ki abi dedim Müsaitseniz
Biz bir eylem yapacağız biz de çeker
misiniz Şimdi bilmiyoruz Yol yordam
Tabii sonra şundan biraz daha sorunun
saf temizliğinden anladı ve hemen şey
yaptı amire sordum mu dedi hangi Amir
dedim şurada dedi amire Gittik Beraber
Arkamdan da geliyor Bu arada
Amirim dedim Şöyle baktı ne var dedi ya
müsaitseniz bir madeniniz yoksa biz de
bir eylem yapacağız dedim ben
şimdi tabi abi şöyle battı kimsiniz siz
Dedi göstermişti Arkadaşlar biz dedim
Eylem yapacağız böyle Tövbe
estağfurullah dedi yürüdü gitti cevap
dahi vermedi aslında Çünkü Adam zaten
stresli orada bir karşılaşma var
öğrenciler var hararetli robot o
polisler var gergin bir ortam var Amirim
bu olayı açması lazım kenara çekildik
bekledik Sonra Ortalık sakin dedi şey
oldu falan ben tekrardan abinin yanına
gittim Amirim ne var dedi Amirim dedim
mananız yoksa biz de bir eylem yapacağız
lütfen izin verin falan kimsiniz dedi
dedim böyle böyle Ne yapacaksınız işte
tüplü böyle baktı Tamam dedi Hadi yapın
dedi o sırada robotların amiri geldi
dedi ki ya dedi amirimiz Ne yapalım dedi
ya siz gidin işte dedi Biz ben
hallederim burayı dedi Tabi orada Biz
biraz bozulduk Çünkü robotlar gidiyor
Şimdi biz Kafamızda şey var Gruba komple
çatışma olacak karşılaşma basın da bizi
çekecek neyse onlar gitti biz banka
çektik bir şeyler yapmaya çalışıyoruz
pankartı önümüze koyuyoruz gözükmüyoruz
işte küçük tüpü bir yere koyamadık falan
Amin Hadi falan dedi Amirim dedim Ne var
dedi ağaca assak olur mu dedim alsın
dedi alsın dedi de şöyle bir durum var
Biz Tamam dua ile ilgili ama biz de
ağaca çıkabilecek adam çıkmadı
Amir ne yaptı verin dedi hızlıca çıktı
canı tez zaten asla ağaca pankartı Hadi
dedi ne yapıyorsanız yapın şöyle
[Alkış]
Tabii bu şeyle bir durum orada Tabii
sıcağı ile eğlence biraz daha aynı böyle
bir sıcak bir ortam oluştu herkes
gülüştü falan orada Amir yanımıza geldi
bak dedi Çağlar pazar günkü mitinginde
amiri benim yerim bunu tatlı tatlı
beraber hallederim dedi tamam dedi Pazar
günü gittik mitinge buluştuk falan
polislere talimat verdi Sıhhiye
meydanında buluşup Sıhhiye Köprüsü'nden
yürüyeceğiz ama Antalya'dan Bu arada
Sorgun ormanı ile ilgili miting bu Ahmet
Necdet Sezer o zaman dilekçe tasarımı
şey yapacak götürülecek
Manavgat'tan da köylüler geldi dernekler
geldi Oradan otobüsle ama topu topu 200
kişiyiz köprüde Yürüyoruz ama bizim
yürüyüşümüz şöyle Hani korku anında
sürüngen beyin devreye girer ve topluca
yürürler ya biz böyle Yürüyoruz gibi ya
mitingteyiz ağır ağır polisler bize
bakıyor acıdılar herhalde biri geldi abi
dedi Öyle yürümeyin size bir
fotoğraflarda böyle çıkarsınız nasıl
yürüyelim
beşerli sıra yapın aranız 2 metre olsun
Cumhuriyet Bayramı gibi düşün dedi tamam
abi düşünelim öyle dedim Sonra art arda
dizildik köprünün öteki tarafına geçtik
şimdi Tabii öyle öğrencilik zamanları
renkli idealist zamanlar
geçti tam 4 sene sonra
sorgu ormanının kıyısındayım üzerimde
takım elbise yanımda son model bir
çiftçisi elimde James Bond çanta
otellere makine satıyorum
acayip bir tezat değişik bir durum yani
o anki ruh halim çok farklı çünkü benim
farklı bir dünyam var ve o Dünya'nın
karşısında olduğum dünyanın içindeyim
kenarındayım bir yerdeyim bir adım attım
bir otel inşaatı var bir iskele var
orada Onun altına doğru ilerlerken bir
şey fark ettim orada bir şey bana
bakıyor
yavaşça kuş gözlemcisi ile kafayı
kaldırdım kukuma bir kumanda Göz Göze
Geldim o an çok tuhaf hissettim yani
orada bir yaşam alanın üzerine Otel
yapılmış ve ben bir sene önce orada
başka bir canlı türünü Gözünü kırpmadan
çekmiştim kokumu alıyor Göz göze gelince
hemen gözümü kaçırmak zorunda kaldım
hızlı
Şunu fark ettim yani bir hafta gittiğim
otelde heyecanla baktım kırlangıç yuvası
ertesi hafta yok baktım diğer otellerde
de böyle ben de şöyle yaptım Doğa
korumacı refleksi sosyal medyada
paylaştım haber yaptım
hiçbir işe yaradı mı yaramadı
Yani belki anlık bu tür paylaşımlarla
bir şey durdurabilirsiniz ama daha
farklı bir çözüm üretmek gerekiyordu Ben
de sordum ya dedim neden bozuyorsunuz
kırlangıç yuvalarını müşteri şikayeti
Daha doğrusu Turizmci deneyimiyle
misafir şikayeti dediler Tamam ben
misafirle konuşayım bozdurmasınlar size
dedim güldüler Ama şöyle bir şey yaptım
bir broşür hazırladım A4 kağıdını Hayır
Aslında şöyle bir şey yazdım
kırlangıçlarda sizler gibi Uzak
ülkelerden gelip otelimizi tercih
ettiler Lütfen onları rahatsız etmeden
izleyiniz
Bununla birlikte kırlangıçta olan
yolculuğumuzu da anlattım Karain
Mağarasında
Binlerce yıl biz kırlangıç yuvasına
bakarak onunla komşu olarak yaşamışız
Hatta ilk yaptığımız çatalhöyük'teki
evlere baktığımızda Kerpiç mimarinin
birebir kırlangıç yuvasından çıktığını
görüyoruz Çünkü o
çatalhöyükteki ilk evleri tepeden
giriliyordu Diğer taraftan biz sonra köy
evleri yaptık Taş Evler yaptık betoner
mi evler yaptık kırlangıç da bizimle
birlikte geldi ve dolayısıyla bizim
kültürümüzün hayatımızın Hep içinde yer
aldık Kırlangıçlar Tabii bu bilgileri
verdiğimizde misafir bir anda misafirin
algısına şu oldu kırlangıç şikayet
edilen değil aslında otelin bir marka
değeri olabilecek konumda bir canlı
haline geldi
bu teorik olarak bu şekilde bir çerçeve
çizdik Ama bunun bütün otellere
yayılması lazım bir iki otelde
denemesini yaptıktan sonra ben dedim ki
bu güzel bir proje oldu Daha önce de çok
proje yaptığım için hemen proje
formatını aldım ve
şöyle bir dernek aradım yani otellere
sözü geçebilecek bir dernek olsun
istedim Otel temizlik görevlilerin ait
olduğu bir Derneğe gittim Dernek
başkanına dedim ki böyle böyle bir proje
var yapalım mı Dinle de dinle de dinledi
kahve içiyoruz bir yandan ya hocam iyi
hoş söylüyorsun da ben de köy çocuğuyum
doğayı Ben de severim daha dün dedi
namussuzlar dedi Çok acayip sağlam
yumurta yapmışlar sopayı vurduk vurduk
dedi bozulmadı dedi en son amonyak
sıktık dedi patır patır yavrular düştü
öldü dedi
yani
Ne dersiniz Şimdi gerçekten sabırlı bir
insan olduğumu söyler gerçekten Bence de
sabırlıyım yani orada Sustum sessizce
ayrıldım Oradan sonra aldım projeyi
Turizmci başka arkadaşlarımızın da
desteğiyle
dünyada Uluslararası bir örgüt olan
scall Antalya kulübüne götürdüm Yani
dünyada 300 kadar kulüp var işte
yaklaşık 100'ün üzerinde ülke iyi bir
organizasyon ve otel yöneticilerinin
Otel patronların dahil olduğu bir kulüp
orada çevreye duyarlı genel müdürler
sayesinde Biz bunu bir proje taslağı
haline getirdik her ay düzenlenen
düzenli yemeklerinde kırlangıç dostu
otellere belli bir belge verdik bunu
otellerin aslılar kırlangıç dostu Otel
diyerek Tabi bu kadar kolay olmadı bir
otel oldu İki Oteli ikna ettik o ara
Özel sektörde çalışmamanın da
avantajıyla çok otele ziyaret edip
onları ikna etmeye de başlamıştım
ve uzun ve Zorlu sürecin sonunda artık
yuva bozmak Aslında bir nevi ayıp haline
geldi
Kırlangıçlar otelin bir değeri olarak
fark edilmeye başladı hem turizmciler
hem de Otel misafirleri açısından bir
farklılık oluştu
Tabi bu kadar kolay olmadı yani o kadar
yıpratıcı bir süreçti ki mesela Bir gün
bir otel davet etti otelin sahibi davet
etti oturduk kahve içiyoruz havuz gibi
müdürünü çağırdı dedi ki bizim kırlangıç
yuvaları vardı onu beyefendilere
gösterir misiniz kadın dediki
talimatınızda onları yıkmıştık
Şimdi tekrar beni lütfen Kendi kendinizi
Lütfen benim yerime yerime koyun ve
şöyle benim açımdan kafamda Şimşekler
açıyor Elim ayağım titriyor ama
yapacağım bir şey yok yani sakinlikle
yavaş yavaş anlatmak lazım oldukça zorlu
bir süreç oldu ve şu tür
belgeler verdik onlarca Otel ziyareti
yaptık ve gerçekten de verimli sonuçlar
aldık buradaki tabi mücadele
turizmciler tarafından değer gördüğü hem
kendi yaptığımız çalışmalar ve Sağ
olsunlar beni bir ödüle layık gördüler
ödülün konsepti gereği herhalde beni
gördüler Çünkü ödülün o seneki konsepti
her şeye rağmen de ve
ödülleri vardır 2017 yılında
İstanbul'daki törenle Antalya Bölge
odaları otel olarak beni layık gördüler
Gerçekten çok teşekkür ederim Bir yandan
da tabii turizmcilere de birçok ödül
kazandırdı sürülebilir Turizm alanında
Bu proje ödülleri aldı ve Tabii o
dönemde Bunlar değişirken bir yandan
böyle Doğa algısı farklılaşmaya
başladığında turizmde bende de başka
algılar oluşmaya başladı çünkü çok iyi
bir şirkette çalışıyorum fakat yapmak
istediğim iş bu değil bir şirket kurmak
istemiyorum Bir dernekte çalışan olmak
istemiyorum çünkü daha hızlı proje
üretmem gerekiyor
o dönemde de Biz şöyle bir şey yaptık
sürülebilir yaşam filmleri festivalin
Antalya ayağını organize ediyorduk ve
orada gerçekten de dünyanın her yerinden
Sürdürülebilir yaşam konusunda mücadele
veren insanların belgesellerini
göstermeye başladık Tabii Bizler de
bunları izledik orada bir tane şey
belgesel serisi çok ilgimi çekti
belgeselde dünyanın farklı yerlerinden
sosyal girişimciliği model alan
projeleri anlatılıyordu ve ben de dedim
ki Evet ya Benim yapmak istediğim iş
asla modeli bu ve ben de o şekilde
İstifa ederek öyle bir yolculuğa çıktım
yani o dönemde tabi benim de cebimde
doğa ile ilgili hazineler var o döneme
kadar çok sayıda Biz yaban Hayat
belgeselleri kültür belgeselleri
hazırlamışız doğa ile ilgili çok fazla
kitap hazırlamışız Dolayısıyla bunlara
da güvenerek yola çıktım ve otellerde
turizmde Doğa farkındalık konusunda çok
sayıda proje üretmeye başladık işte Doğa
kitapları belgeseller tanıtım filmleri
konuşmalar misafir deneyimleri
uygulamalarla bölge coğrafyasının ve
otel bahçesinin doğasını keşfetmeye
başladık ki aslında kırlangıç projesi
ile böyle bir merak turizmde oluşmaya
başladı Yani kırlangıç varsa bu bir
kelebek de var acaba bu kelebeğin adı ne
Bu kuşun adı ne Bu ağacın hikayesi Ne
merakı daha da büyüdü ve biz bunu
kitaplarla
50.000'nin üzerinde baskıyla 5 ayrı
değilde basılarak Turizm misafirlerine
ulaşmasını sağladık bunlar böyle devam
ederken Tabii bir yandan da okullarla
çalışmaya başladık Ve her sene binlerce
çocuğu
Antalya'nın doğasını ve Türkiye'nin
doğasını tanımak üzere Doğa
hazinelerimizi keşfetmek üzere doğaya
çıkmaya başladık 4-6 yaştan üniversite
son sınıfa kadar öğrencilerle elimizde
dürbünler teleskoplar hem doğayı
izliyoruz Hem o doğanın o ağaçların o
kuşların Bizim kültürümüzde olan
hikayesini yeniden keşfetmeye
çalışıyoruz niye yeniden Çünkü zaten
bizden iki ay önceki kuşak böyle bir
uyum içindeydi doğayla fakat bizim
doğayla olan ritmimizde doğa ile olan
iletişimimizde bir kopukluk yaşandı Biz
de işte bu kopukluğa bir şekilde
çocuklarla çözüm bulmak için aslında bir
yandan da onlarla çalışmaya başladık
Şimdi böyle geziyoruz bazen antik
kentlere gidiyoruz
mağarasına çıkıyoruz Karain Mağarasında
çocuklara
binlerce yıla yayılan bu hikayesini
anlatıyorum
Teşekkür ederim çok sağ ol
[Müzik]